[Music]
welcome back careful boys we are very
careful boys today we got can today we
got an interesting conversation we were
kind of having off camera about how our
parents
have kind of
accepted or adjusted to the fact that we
all have kind of weird jobs and weird
lives yeah because over the years i just
realized that i'm surrounded by
circus clowns yes everywhere all around
me right
and um i do have friends from you know
like the professional sector like just
traditional jobs or whatever but then i
was like
in this room today
nobody here
actually works in that field and all of
us
i mean you like can like i think from
childhood as your first job or like you
working was like periodics and touring
the world
that was yeah i mean i had a part-time
but i only worked for that like but that
was like the start of your career and
you've been in entertainment ever since
right and then so like i was like oh
[ __ ] how did your guys's parents take
that oh so my parents actually
they've always been supportive of my
hobbies but then when i got older
graduated high school they're expecting
you to go to college
learn whatever and they're like i didn't
think you were gonna [ __ ] try to
dance for life what the hell is wrong
with you then i actually the reason why
i started dancing more was because i
didn't get into college or the college
that i wanted to get into which was cal
state long beach right because there was
this thing that happened where i got
admitted and so i was like cool pick my
classes and then like three days before
class starts i get a letter i'm like oh
we cancelled your mission i'm like why
did you do that yeah
they did that to me because they they
looked back at my record and they're
like oh we found this one thing like it
was like in my english class or
something i got a d so like just because
of that they're like now we don't want
you to come to school anymore so from
that i was like all right i guess i'm
gonna dance and do my part-time job d
for dance yeah d for dance but then
their reaction was kind of like they're
like okay you can dance but just make
sure you go back to school make sure you
you know get a job and all this so they
basically kind of didn't want me to keep
doing it but i just kept doing it anyway
but yeah
that sounds
pretty kind and reasonable yeah they
didn't get mad because it's like what
can you really do i'm surprised your
parents didn't do the traditional beat
your ass to be a pharmacist thing no no
they actually didn't want me to be any
of that they wanted me to be like like a
architect or something like my dad you
know something like he does an architect
yeah he's an artist he does a
contracting are you an only child no i
have an older brother yeah we did a
whole thing about him yeah was i here
for that
no no no
i wasn't either what does your older
brother do so uh i don't want to talk
about what he does let's just put it
like that yeah oh what the [ __ ] you'd
have to kill us and then uh okay how
about this he's he's a rapper
you know he's a rapper and they
they don't care what he does like my
parents don't care i only ask because
it's like like for example i have an
older sister who's very successful has
children does like regular [ __ ] so i
feel like my parents are a little more
relaxed on me do they oh so they don't
compare you because they feel like we
already got one out of them outside of
me they already got a good one maybe the
subconscious like i'm the boy so like i
if i produce the sun then like the name
goes on but at the same time i have like
the second most common last name in the
world who gives a [ __ ] that's very true
you know what i mean very true you must
restore the lee name yeah the lead
dynasty is definitely under threat if i
don't produce errors i know they're like
i don't know
but i asked because you know like i can
understand how parents sometimes end up
doing that yeah yeah that's a different
answer than i was expecting dude yeah um
the only time i ever felt like my dance
career was like kind of done was like
after we actually already made it and i
started traveling a lot and then because
i wasn't home anymore she would always
be like okay you know when you're done
traveling make sure you go back to
school please like you have to and i was
like after you're done making all of
this money traveling the world [ __ ]
all these hoes make sure you go back to
school yeah they were still very adamant
of me going back to school and getting
that normal life because they knew that
maybe
maybe they foresaw it maybe they were
like maybe this entertainment stuff
doesn't really last that long because it
really didn't i mean it lasts for like
10 years but like you know now i'm
thinking like man they were probably
right like i probably should have done
something on top of dance but i never
did dan did you ever tell them that your
mom might [ __ ] come
what the [ __ ] no that's a good thing
you want that reaction she might be like
she's like i knew it
so you're gonna go to school you're
gonna go to school you knew it um
city westminster
she's like where's she from my mom city
is where she's from yes they come too
bro mom's come too you're boyina park oh
one of our men no no that's where silk
city is
that's my hood baby
is that where it is in suck city right
yeah totally i like to work with this
guy
with my first job
this guy is so cute my mom's from
vietnam what job did you say you quit
oh i was an auto part delivery driver so
i worked at a auto parts like they they
basically did resale like they buy it
was it an asian business no it was like
a white dude
yeah
like it's like when you when you're at a
mechanic and then they need a part for
that car they call in yeah
yeah but
it was like whatever because i just kind
of drove around listening to music it
was super chill but then the opportunity
came up to dance and i was like dude
i'ma quit this [ __ ] dude can i ask what
your parents do unless you guys all went
over this already no his dad's an
architect right targets
my mom used to i can't [ __ ] tell you
i can't tell you well that's all i can
say my mom used to work at china
airlines so she used to be not a flight
attendant but the people that work at
the counter
and then
she became uh she did nails
yeah so with me yeah now she does nails
have you been to an auto zone before
have you ever walked into an auto zone
and just yelled i'm in the zone
and the guys there are just like god
damn another one no i walk in there and
i go oh oh oh all right they're like
wrong
you get the [ __ ] out of here yeah they
throw a wrench at you and [ __ ] no it's
um
actually yeah i i actually delivered to
like pep boys and like all the like
honda centers oh they're actually
answering my question
what a sport i care i care about your
thank you bro opinions so hypothetically
we're going back to the topic um
what does what did your parents think of
what you do now yeah how about now oh no
you're not dancing anymore when you
gotta go to school yeah i actually edit
videos now and i do a video editing
company yeah you have a successful yeah
yeah it's my vlogs yeah it's jk he had
it's mike tyson he had its tiger belly
he had its who else um
[ __ ] i don't know this there's a bunch
yeah you know cat from uh
but she was here before oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah no we don't know her okay well
anyway not the one who was here
yesterday right yeah and barbara i'm
starting with barbara too oh cool yeah
just like our our circle pretty much we
don't we don't mention barbell here
anymore mike tyson's not really our
circle unless you talk about uh barbell
brigand right by rizzo uh liz yeah we
talk about that we'll talk about that
reference the
does your mom feel like it's more
legitimate now because you have an
editing company yeah and so now like
when i have friends over she knows like
oh those are my like employees they're
like mad dance friends yeah those are
dance friends are the worst yeah the
answer suck yeah dude i haven't i
haven't toured in like over a year
because of kovit yeah well we still did
show us doing copic actually we did like
one or two shows it was it was super
random but then
after that this is like the first year
where i'm like okay no more dancing i'm
just going to focus on business cool
yeah what about what about relationship
stuff are you doing any of that right
now no staying out of the game yeah it's
a [ __ ] rocket huh it's like it's been
two years now yeah it's a [ __ ] racket
how about you nick did your what was
your mom's reaction like you want to be
a [ __ ] fighter the hell you can't
even fight me yeah honestly
there was a little bit of that she's
like you're a little [ __ ] you'll never
make it son that's what she would say to
me uh no but the because same sentence
your actual goal was to be a pro fighter
right that was the first before you got
into fitness and stuff yeah so i started
i wanted to fight
and then they were all looking at me
like i was [ __ ] crazy but i would
tell them that like oh i'm just joining
this this karate school that's what i
told them and they were like oh okay i'm
just doing karate nothing crazy so you
didn't tell them like you're ufc no it
was none of that [ __ ] and then i came
back with like my ear all [ __ ] up
and they were all like wrong with it
what's wrong with it nothing it's normal
now i didn't realize it was that hard it
touches it's hard if i look if what are
you doing oh my god
i've seen that during fights i've seen
that they do that oh that's a move but
yeah
you [ __ ] dig your ear they do that
well because it's like it's it's like
calcified so
really so you use it like a golf ball on
the chest nah not like that only when i
want to for party tricks like this um
but
yeah so where was oh yeah so i wanted to
start fighting and then once i started
getting my ear all [ __ ] up my mom was
like mortified
like there was times where i would like
talk to her and she'd look at me in the
eye and then slowly just look at my ear
like mid conversation and then just be
like but it's like the opposite i do
it's like
whoa
she looks at it that way
she really has to get that figured out
but she
it's a problem actually what was she
what did you say she said but she would
like look at it and be like you know i
gave birth to you and you had normal
ears and now you're all [ __ ] up like
she would say that [ __ ] to me that's
actually crazy
but but if you knew my mom it'd be like
oh that's just normal mom like my mom
[ __ ] but did that actually i mean
because maybe she's trying to reach out
to you i've never actually gotten to
talk to you about this but did that
actually bother you when that started to
happen to your ears no no no at first i
was like
it was just part of it because in the
culture in the mma culture it's it's
seen as like a
a badge of honor like it is something
really cool right but at the time which
was hard for me was when i first started
training i had these really sick ass
ears but i still sucked
so i got it really early so everyone's
like oh you must be a black belt and i
was like no
i just got [ __ ] up yeah yeah it was it
was purely just me getting my ass kicked
all the time and then my ear got all
[ __ ] up that's still something though
thanks man you have to get your ass
kicked if you want to get better i don't
know if you know this but i'm really
good at getting knocked out yeah he's
the guy i'm the guy he's a knockout
artist of being knocked out
you learn how to get up more yeah
sometimes i just lay there i don't
really get up that much but no uh so
when i would start fighting and stuff
and i would i had a lot of fun doing it
and it was great but i remember the
first time
i had my first like mma fight
i was like cutting weight in my bathroom
and it was like i had to use the bathtub
and
what does that mean so cutting weight is
i would have to weigh in at say at the
time i'd walk around maybe like 145 150
pounds but i had to fight at 135 pounds
yeah oh no i'm aware of that but why are
you putting weight in a bathtub well
because what i would do is you would
epsom salt bath yeah just jerk off some
salt bath and get really really hot
sweat sweat sweat and then you would lay
on the floor put a bunch of towels on
you and then you would just sweat like
like a cocoon
and i remember i was doing that in my
parents bathroom because they had a
bathtub and my dad just didn't really
know that i was like gonna do any of
this stuff like he was just kind of like
oh you train whatever he just thought i
was like doing this for fitness
and then he wakes up in the middle of
the night and sees me in a [ __ ] he
sees a sun and a cocoon of towels on the
[ __ ] floor and i'm like i'm on
death's door because it sucks cutting
weight is awful you feel terrible
and then i wasn't expecting him to give
me this reaction and this is the night
before the fight i was gonna fight the
next day
and uh and it was like a big moment for
me at least in my head and he just was
like pissed he was like yo what the [ __ ]
are you doing my dad usually doesn't
react to most things but he was like
what are you doing why the [ __ ] are you
even doing this
did you know what you were doing well i
told him he was like
i was cocooning and i was like i have a
fight tomorrow and he goes what the [ __ ]
why are you even doing this stop
fighting you don't need to be doing this
[ __ ] like he was like matt
just tell him you don't want no trouble
yeah don't watch trouble and beat them
up with your jacket
so like that was kind of a weird head
trip like going into that fight that
next day
and being like oh dude [ __ ] nobody
wants me to do this [ __ ] but it wasn't
let me envision your father you whip
that guy's ass and i actually won that
was i actually oh nice but at the same
time you got knocked down and you won
but just qualifications
he used a legal strike
he gave me the steel chair and triple h
came from the [ __ ] entrance
they got double-teamed
dude
yeah but it was like a laborious
three-count yeah
but yeah like and that was pretty much
it but as far as my career now and
going into coaching they're actually
relieved that i just wanted to do more
of that so they're more afraid of your
health and injury because because when i
got started getting more like i got a
couple of head injuries back to back
like later on in my career
and they were really [ __ ] not okay
with it like it was actually quite
emotional bro like i remember
having that concussion i was freaking
the [ __ ] out my family they were
freaking out they were worried like
you're gonna be this kid's gonna be a
[ __ ] vegetable you know because i was
having like concussion syndrome stuff
and it was weird because like i remember
like laying there like kind of crying
and [ __ ] because i was like this is all
i wanted to do
but i don't think i could handle these
types of injuries like i'm just
not well equipped for this and i
remember my girl was there
she saw me really emotional and now it
was just me talking to my girl about it
like yo this is [ __ ] up like i don't
know what the [ __ ] i'm gonna do because
i at that time i already spent so much
time and effort in the sport and i still
didn't have like a crazy amateur career
either but it was just like it was just
emotional for me because i was like this
is who i thought i was and having to get
away from that identity was a weird
thing but i think i really found what i
actually really wanted to which is
coaching because i feel like you're
pretty good i mean i used to train with
you all the time and it was really fun
like it felt it didn't even feel like i
was like i had a coach it was just like
oh let's go hang out with nick and he's
going to tell me how to get buff and
[ __ ]
yeah so i'm thankful that i went through
all that stuff because it was it was
experience that i will never you know
like
competing is one thing like that's a
whole different mindset and i think for
me at the time i wasn't ready for that
so yeah it was good but yeah i mean like
you like i've never seen david lose
weight before but with nick he not only
lost weight but he also learned how to
fight it's crazy and everyone says
dave's good now he's good man it was
pretty good but think about david though
i wish i could take all the credit but
david he's one of those guys that's like
you could make him do anything once he
has he sets his mind to it he's gonna
[ __ ] go just take all the credit dude
it's david because of you though i heard
he's non-stop getting knocked out now
thanks to you no he stopped training
with me now he's fine
what does your parents do my my mom
doesn't work but my dad was a sound
editor so he also he already had like a
non-traditional job yeah he kind of and
dude his his story is crazy like that
dude he immigrated here when he was like
six or something like no like seven from
taiwan and they lived in san francisco
and then he left there
came to la started work in the mail room
at dreamworks and then got a sound
editing gig from there so he was like
one of those dudes that kind of just
like found his way in and he actually
worked on crazy movies like he did a
bunch of indiana jones movies he did 48
hours like like just all over the place
and he worked for like sony also he was
already working in an entertainment yeah
like that that was that was his thing
and he used to always tell me like you
should get entertainment i was like what
the [ __ ] am i here that's like the most
opposite asian dad story i've ever heard
like he's telling you to do
entertainment yeah he's like you should
do that like he wanted me to do like kid
acting and i was like no
kid acting oh what the [ __ ] am i gonna
do wait so how do they feel how do your
parents feel now that they know that
you're they don't do kid acting right
now i don't i don't tell them [ __ ]
acting on jk news
i just tell them i'm like yeah i just do
this like podcast thing i just kind of
keep it real [ __ ] brief you know but
but but they're just like not proud of
us
i get it i get it i'm like don't watch
this [ __ ] show does your dad critique
the sound editing
but you know i don't think my dad
actually knows that i do this because he
actually just recently came back from
taiwan he's been in taiwan since the
pandemic so i actually i haven't seen
him i was supposed to go see him this
weekend find out he's in vegas i don't
know what the [ __ ] you haven't seen your
father maybe i saw him
at sapphire
we're playing we're playing phone tag
you know what i mean but he he dipped
out there because of the panda i think
he he had a stroke before the pandemic
and he had kind of like weird mobility's
legs holy crap did he recover from it he
did jesus christ it's a [ __ ] huge
thing he uh he he went to
taiwan because he doesn't believe in
like western medicine you know what i
mean but he's the most americanized
asian dude ever but he'd rather do
ginseng yeah low-key so he's a hollywood
white girl hollister he kind of well
it's also probably maybe uh
uh western uh prices yeah oh true
because they get free health care out
there right but he's also the most
stubborn man i've ever met mother well i
mean most dads are pretty stubborn you
know i mean so it's like i tell him like
hey you should probably do physical
therapy and he's like yeah that shit's a
racket
[ __ ] like different he knows the word
racket my dad actually [ __ ] hates um
what are they called with like a
chiropractor he [ __ ] hates those guys
because his back cracks and he's like
a lot of them are [ __ ] charlatans
dudes yeah a lot of them just put out
[ __ ] it's crazy but there's some
really good chiropractors but i like it
when my balls are adjusted and then my
back feels better what the [ __ ] have you
ever had your ears cracked like it feels
good it's [ __ ] crazy i like all the
cracking stuff because it feels good but
yeah i don't [ __ ] know it but even
the chiropractor is like i do this [ __ ]
for show
like i just get people to feel good i
pop out pop but like all the stuff that
actually hurts like the soft tissue and
the heart like the the grass
the [ __ ] bleeding like that's just
the real stuff but yeah one acupressure
or acupuncture session is like 10
chiropractor sessions for me really yeah
i could push it legit hey what do you
guys what do you guys parents think
about like especially for the dancer
boys here we have a lot of them in the
room all four of us you know the you're
when your dad's kind of like a macho
dude and [ __ ] and like you don't you
know the idea of dance especially where
i grew up it was kind of like seen as
like for chicks especially in that
generation too yeah for sure because you
guys made that [ __ ] cool yeah exactly do
you guys did you guys get any help from
like the males in your life like coming
out i didn't because the [ __ ] i was
practicing didn't even look like i was
dancing
looked like i was just practicing stunts
so my dad was ryan's ryan styles
suicidal style that's what my
sacrificial stuff my dad was always was
kind of like your dad was like what the
[ __ ] are you doing that yeah you're
gonna [ __ ] hurt yourself didn't
understand like why i would possibly to
like it didn't even an equate to dance
but then also i kept it a secret for so
long uh because you know in seventh day
adventist religion you're not allowed to
dance what whoa so her religion was like
so it worked for me that what i was
doing looked like acro so uh they never
caught on
until like you know they thought it was
acrobatics because breakdancing so you
started doing choreo well i also tried
to not make it look as serious when i
was at home
you know i felt like the [ __ ] the
story of the capoeira origin where it's
like you try to hide your self-defense
so then like it just looked like i was
[ __ ] around all the time and then
when i would go to school i would like
go to the gym like really early and then
i would i would just break in there and
like really try super hard so you never
told them i want to be a dancer no i
never told them i never told them at all
that i wanted to be a dancer until i was
on [ __ ] tv see that's how you do it
asian kids lie to your parents don't
[ __ ] tell them your dreams do it
secretly and then boom you're on tv turn
on channel five right now don't invite
your parents to your tournaments or any
competitions i remember the first
judicial tournament i did and i didn't
prepare for it at all i went there i won
a couple matches and my parents came and
they missed those matches my parents
came my sister came the final match i
get my arm like popped
in front of all of them
so they're already thinking like this
kid's [ __ ] that's gonna be so tough
getting knocked yeah
get his arm and i'm like i had to drive
home in the miata and my arms all [ __ ]
up covered in ice and it was stick so
i'm like
yeah it's terrible dude it's [ __ ]
weird yeah that's bad yeah so i got away
with a lot because it didn't really
uh occur to them at all and they didn't
say nothing yeah and then i and even if
i was doing like dance stuff at school
it just looked like
anything like just like a side thing
you're doing like i tried to make it
look as not serious as possible but in
your heart were you like i'm pursuing
that 100 and then and then uh and then
when i was on so you think you could
dance this you can't [ __ ] hide
anymore so everyone from my church knew
my old school knew and then uh yeah my
parents were pretty pissed really yeah
really they're like you brought shame to
our christmas
that looks pretty crappy to be like i
think it also sucks parentally like
regardless of how you feel about dance
it sucks parentally for all these other
people like because both my parents work
in hospitals and then for all these
other filipino like uh nurses they know
to go we saw your son he's so good and
they're just like you what like it makes
them look dumb and like bad parents
and then like and they're not involved
yeah blindsided that's why they're gonna
do what my mom did you know just be like
oh yeah yeah i knew this and then for
production like for for so you think
when i when i so i was on sony dance
season one and they loved the um and i
didn't i thought it was um audition for
dance 360. i didn't know because it
didn't have a name yet it was so new so
then uh we did they did a bunch of home
story stuff and they were like tell us
like about your background everything i
didn't know any better i just said all
the true stuff and i was like oh yeah
you know this is that my parents they're
like
and it they couldn't even it couldn't
even uh
they couldn't even comprehend why my
parents would be that unsupportive of it
but to me that shit's normal you know
yeah back then i feel like the asian
typical [ __ ] story that we've all
heard so much about my parents don't
approve like that was that was normal
they didn't know it at the time now it's
like don't even bother saying it what
about dance it's kind of funny because
it's like footloose villains
[Laughter]
it really is it's kind of like dumb they
try to make that stuff so dramatic
sometimes they put all that [ __ ] on tv
about my parents not wanting me to do it
and my parents were pretty sad about
that yeah and i think it's like you
didn't give us a chance to even accept
it well i think they were sad my mom i
remember my mom saying like hey can you
just not say that anymore
but even though it was true still like
they were still like hey you're gonna go
back to school after the show is done
right and this was like the start of my
solo career when right afterwards i was
doing a bunch of like cool stuff i was
traveling teaching um all by myself and
then i think the guilt like got to me i
was like [ __ ] man i should go back to
school so then i actually went back to
school and then i went uh back to
cypress college to finish some more
prereqs because my my big thing was like
i always wanted to go to like a proper
university but i didn't do well enough
in high school so then i went back to
cypress college tons of people would go
what the [ __ ] are you doing here because
that that like
i guess surge of like fame hadn't died
down yet so i was really embarrassed i
was like dude i'm [ __ ] going it
looked like i failed yeah but then i was
like [ __ ] i just kept saying i'm doing
it for my parents [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] like
just just don't let it get to you but
what happened after that and then i i
did i did really well i got i got a full
ride to uci and then i went to
university of uh california irvine my
parents were super proud they put the
[ __ ]
uci pennant on the wall like they were
like this is finally like our dream for
you thank you so much that's crazy and
then uh one quarter left till graduation
i left to do abd
amazing
how do you feel about that
they were pissed all over again
you are the [ __ ] most interesting man
that's so awesome they were disappointed
all over again because they were like
you got a humps up and i didn't have to
pay a dime for uci like it was all like
that's great so why don't you just send
them a [ __ ] screenshot of your
celebrity network 19 million then
they're gonna ask for some of it yeah
but you lived like a way crazier like
because you didn't go to school or
because you didn't finish yeah but it's
you know like the thing that i and i
completely don't fault them for it it's
like as a parent you want for your kids
what you understand to be the best
possible thing and it's like they did
that formula and i 100 understand why it
worked yeah yeah yeah and it completely
did and honestly it would work for me
too and they want the best but i just
can't live with making that choice but
what i like about this generation is we
broke that
perspective of all the asian parents
because now and now we have so much more
competition can why the [ __ ] do they
want to pursue this
it's a terrible idea yeah i think uh i
that's why like you know like it it also
annoys me when i see other like asian
dancers like be like i can't believe my
parents don't support me or they're like
that's their home story i'm like dude
you and [ __ ] millions of other ages
yeah
because you see the other kids being
supported by their whole families
they're there they have cards for them
they're like clapping for them and when
you see that you're kind of envious it's
like what the [ __ ] you know it's like
you think of like like my in my mind i
always imagine like these white little
league boys that their parents are there
and they're so passionate about the game
but then i'm a [ __ ]
like i'm eight 22 and then my parents
can't really do the same you know like
dude even then the parents were there
and they're like kill them [ __ ] kill
him who gives a [ __ ]
get the ball to third who gives a [ __ ]
but that's about white i think that's
why it's i think it's an asset i think
everybody in that same position that i
was in which there's a [ __ ] shitload
of them that's your biggest asset i
think that you don't need to have that
you know like it's well the converse is
pretty wild like your parents are too
interested and then you're in pageants
and you're like
[ __ ] hate my life yeah i just want to
die it's not even your dream mom's like
hey big let's get a big one cause that's
so weird that's even more that's way
[ __ ] worse dude isis coach's kid he
was like we saw him since he was five to
like 12 and every day his dad wanted to
be a fighter so [ __ ] bad but this kid
hated every single day of practice he
was really talented sucks but
guarantee you i think he stopped
fighting now because he's he's just so
burnt out made him hate it yeah exactly
once he kissed a girl that was it dude
that's the trick to good parenting just
force them to do what you know they're
not gonna like so they can do what you
actually want them to do be a doctor
yeah
reverse psychology like hey come on why
aren't you dancing ken junior come on
1678 and then he [ __ ] hates it so
much he becomes the doctor i'm like yes
no yeah
i feel like that'll happen what i liked
the most about this conversation is bart
wasn't here to stand up as soon as ryan
started talking
and cut the camera
it was too good
great start great story feel the feels
you